so here we go let me welcome you to the
show all right hot breath verse welcome
back to the hot breath podcast your
weekly guide to comedy mastery
I'm your host comedian Joel Byers my
guest today has over 100 million views
on YouTube alone with several million
across all of the social media platforms
but his viral success did not come
without hard work starting comedy almost
two decades ago in New York City handing
out flyers in the winter wearing
newspaper under his jacket to stay warm
14 years later of hard work he hits
viral gold
he has since been an author he's owned
comedy clubs he's produced comedy
festivals he has his own comedy grant
where he supports other comedians as
well and you know here at hot breath
were all about supporting comedians so
this gentleman is the perfect guest so
welcome to the show Steve Hofstetter I
like that you knew your [__] like that
you did your homework so many times like
you do uh like you do a morning radio
show and I'm like so uh tell us about
yourself right in front of you man
exactly yeah I have a whole sheet of
research I don't know yeah look at that
nice so I know our time is limited yes
so you are the heckler Wrangler so maybe
we start there in terms of the core
listeners all around the world comedians
and comedy nerds yo maybe break down how
to handle a heckler for us so the way
you handle a heckler is you make sure
the audience hates them more than you do
you give them enough rope to hang
themselves
you don't wrangle them they wrangle
themselves and the other thing is that
voice that tells you what to say and
what not to say shut it off and just go
with your instinct now the trick is you
have to not be horrible human being you
know you have to not have it like when
Michael Richards said what he said the
tape doesn't show you how awful the
people were before he said what he said
but that doesn't matter because he said
something horrible because he thought
something horrible I would never even
thought what he said let alone set it
out loud in front of human beings so you
have to
make sure you're a decent human being
also so you don't cross the line and
anger can come off a little yes one of
the things that I have to constantly
remind myself is if you can lean back
instead of leaning forward it'll come
off much better interests because that
person is trying to get to you mm-hmm
and so if you can just laugh at how
miserably they're failing then it'll be
much better than being like well I'll
tell you another thing your piece of
[__] you know you it's a little bit
better than so you almost let them like
hang themselves in a sense you do and
there's one actually I didn't get on
film where it's prot it might be the
meanest thing I've ever said to anybody
I was in Ann Arbor at the comedy
showcase and there was a very big bridal
party and there was one woman who would
not shut up she was making everything
about her and finally I was talking to
her and I found out she was the maid of
honor and first I did the whole like oh
great so you're gonna be talking at this
wedding be like you're making this about
you your friends special day and this is
still about you and finally when she
wouldn't shut up I said I really wish
you luck and catching the bouquet at the
wedding and she said oh I'm married and
I go yeah but your husband's gonna leave
you you're gonna die alone so I wish you
luck and so I mean I I told a woman her
husband would leave her and I and she
died alone and the audience applauded
because they wanted way worse for her
than what I said they were like oh he's
going real easy on her because she was
just the worst right and that's the
that's really the trick it's the
gladiator you know you you win the crowd
you win the day
there's a big learning curve with this
and sure a question asked all comics on
here is like their most epic booze story
or epic bombing it's like what what
comes to mind in your long career when I
learned well if if we're keeping it on
hecklers when I learned that you needed
the crowd on your side was there was
this kid when Facebook was starting to
pop in 2005 there's this one kid who
would send me hateful messages all the
time
mm-hmm and you know your pictures tied
to it I knew who he was I knew where he
lived I knew what school he went to
you went to Indiana University and so I
was performing in Bloomington at bears
place and this kid comes to the show
he's in the front row I recognize him
immediately
and he is sarcastically laughing so it's
right in the beginning my set he's just
going ha ha ha ha which most of the
audience can't hear first of all which
is part of why when someone says
something to me I repeat it back I
repeat it back both to give me another
second to think but also so that
everyone in the back also hears it good
trick but this guy is just basically
laughing a little bit weird now I know
he's an [__] I have a history with
him that crowd doesn't have a history
with him so when I go off on him and I
try to tell them oh everything's fallen
oh we're good we're in a prop closet
this is funky when I try to tell him
like when I try to tell them that oh
this is a guy who's been sending me
nasty messages for the last six months I
just look like an insane person mm-hmm
like I just look like like it's all I'm
delusional and I lost that crowd so hard
and there were maybe 10 people in that
crowd who still liked me by the end of
that show oh I just had to do 45 minutes
of just just people not rooting for me
at all and at one point during that show
I even said I know I'm not doing well
like I had to say that out loud
because they weren't on my side I went
off on him too quickly
I I needed to let him I needed to let
him prove to them that he was an [__]
right you can't be the only one who
knows they're an [__] boom yeah we've
all gotten a little antsy on stage and
that's but that happened at the
beginning of the beginning to set and
you had to ride out 45 like two minutes
in it was it was rough it was really
really rough the MC was a friend of mine
he was the regular host there around
Wilhelm and he afterward he made a joke
about how like you know we here at bears
place really like to support make-a-wish
and you know it was which I deserved
absolutely that was that was a horrible
set and it was because the rest of the
set I didn't do anything different I
just no matter what I said it wouldn't
work
they hated me you forged the sword and
now you've become almost known as like
the comedian destroys
secular guy and your but it's not
without savvy strategy behind it and you
seem to be tapped into you've always
been a forward thinker at 18 you create
your own sports website you were a lot
of people give Dane Cook credit on
MySpace but you were actually in the
myspace game as well I I was although
you know Dane was bigger than I was for
sure I've always tried to figure out
what is the next thing nice and you know
five years ago I was telling every comic
get on reddit get on reddit get on
reddit and most of them didn't listen to
me and my video going number one I read
it is what that's what popped em hmm
and so there's and there's a lot of
things that you always look for what's
next and you don't know it till you find
it and sometimes you'll be wrong the
heckler stuff I never tried for that to
be a thing
it happened organically I would just
post videos to YouTube because I wanted
to post stuff that wasn't my set I
wanted to post outtakes or material I
stopped doing right right but I didn't
want to post stuff I was doing currently
and so a lot of those outtakes were
heckler stuff cuz that's what wasn't
supposed to be in the set right and but
what I did notice I noticed it started
touching a nerve and that's when I
started leaning into it now I'm fully
aware that being known for dealing with
hecklers is not the only thing you want
to be known for but I see it as a
gateway to my comedy for sure it is when
that heckler video popped the video ID
posted just before was a self-produced
special and so three million people came
and watched that video in three days and
then another half a million of them
stayed and watched the special and
that's how I started I went from at the
time I had 95 thousand subscribers now I
have over half a million hmm and it was
because I had other content on there so
you know the heckler stuff I I like that
it's done well I don't regret that it's
done well at all a lot of times people
who try to make fun of it are actually
doing it inaccurately will it be like
comedian destroys heckler in a bunch of
capital letters and exclamation points
and I'm like I've never had a video with
with anything like that oh and I wasn't
saying you know no I know I know
you're not I I'm saying that like it's
funny to me that the idea of people
using clickbait titles people using all
caps people use an exclamation points
I've never done that it's the people who
have tried to copy what I've done who
have gone too far
and then I get made fun of for that and
a because the people who make fun of
that stuff are lazy and if anybody's
watching and you know I've had people
tell me the heckler thing is a gimmick
and it's funny because one of the people
who told me that literally perform
santim comedy in a bear costume in a
laundromat the heckler thing isn't a
gimmick or just part of what we do mm-hm
it's that would be like saying that slam
dunking is a gimmick instead of you know
oh you you just gotta shoot threes and
it's like no that's one part of your
game exactly but part of the game for
any santim comic is being able to ad-lib
and I'm a better ad lib er than I am a
writer and I'm certainly and I'm a
better writer than I am an actor so I
you know I have to lean into what I'm
good at
what would you tell comics is next now
what is it still YouTube and like having
thumbnails and I I don't I don't know
yet I think that you know Facebook is
Facebook video a lot of people like oh
no one's on Facebook anymore except for
billions of people right yeah no yeah a
lot of cool people aren't on Facebook
but it doesn't matter cuz cool people
are too cool to buy tickets boom so put
your videos up on Facebook never click
bait because click baiting is incendiary
titles that you don't deliver on you can
have it send iary titles if you deliver
on them don't post screenshots of stuff
that's not happening in the video mmm
and you know just just make sure to be
honest about what you're delivering and
be accessible in terms of what site is
next I don't know maybe tick tock you
know tick tock is popping right now it's
kind of the new vine it's a platform
that lends itself well to some people
and not well to others so it depends on
what you're trying to do Instagram video
is doing really well I would say
subtitle your videos it takes extra time
when you're editing but make sure your
videos are well shot and subtitled every
comic whoo
believes in yourself at all invest in a
camera it doesn't have to be anything
super nice you get a 4k camera for $600
now so you can get a used 1080 for a
hundred fifty bucks and if you can't
spend 150 bucks on your career why would
anyone else boom invest in yourself
alright so we got a we got to land this
plane here yeah
in closing do you have any closing
advice for comics out there
what can you bestow us with I would say
a be patient it takes a while it
absolutely takes a while be create all
the time and and not just writing
stand-up but find something that you're
good at and create that whether it is
you know and don't just do something cuz
it worked for someone else you know you
don't watch this and be like oh I can
handle hecklers it's like if you can
great but if not maybe you should do a
web series maybe you should do vlogs
maybe you know maybe you should host a
podcast maybe you shouldn't just because
it works for someone else we I guess
although advice boils down to one thing
every day we strive to be original
onstage being a hack is the worst thing
in this business but so many people are
hacks offstage hmm there are so many
people who their promo their web
presence their social media it's all
done because they saw someone else do it
imagine if you're gonna write a joke
because you saw someone else write a
joke that same way so figure out every
comedian is creative every comedian is
intelligent you can't be a comedian
unless you're those things so be
creative intelligent be creative and
intelligent offstage and that will help
free up the space to be those things on
stage alright the final thing we end
with could you look into the camera let
them know who you are and why they
should listen to hot breath hey I'm
Steve Hofstetter and listen to hot
breath because I just told you to I
think I haven't seen any other episodes
but I'm sure they're great
alright Steve thanks beyond hot breath
my man thank you very much have fun up
there Thanks there you go hot breath
averse Steve Hofstetter hey hot brother
and sister if you love comedy as much as
we do here at hot breath click the
subscribe button to join the hot breath
of
and then watch more videos to get even
more comedy tips